what's going on guys bang bang this week
for the Bitcoin update all I want to do
is talk about the Federal Reserve we
know that for the last 12 months they've
continued to try to destroy demand and
get inflation under control they're in
control and it's all one big trade all
asset prices are suffering at their
hands now they haven't been as
successful in getting inflation under
control as they probably have hoped
right now for the trailing two years the
inflation rate in America according to
the official numbers is about 16 it was
6.8 percent last year and still over
seven percent this year that compounding
growth of the inflation rate is hurting
the American family now as the FED has
destroyed that demand and raised
interest rates they've brought all asset
prices down stocks bonds everything that
you can think of real estate Commodities
and crypto they continue to try to
punish investment assets and consumer
good pricing to try to get that
inflation rate down this past week we
saw another half a percent interest rate
raise by the Federal Reserve this
signals that maybe they're going to be a
little bit less aggressive but the big
question becomes when will they pivot
now that pivot is important to pay
attention to not necessarily because of
the pivot itself but because it will be
a return to the loose monetary policy as
we get back to a loose monetary policy
you're gonna have more and more money
sloshing around the economy and my guess
is that assets across the board
including Bitcoin will go back up in a
positive direction one other key point
to pay attention to is the long-term
damage of inflation all throughout the
2010s we saw just under 19 inflation
across the decade but in the first 35
months as Lance Lampert pointed out this
past week we actually saw inflation come
in at over 15 and a half percent that
means that we are doing quite a bit of
damage on the inflation measurement on
top of that Charlie bolilo pointed out
that we've had negative wage growth for
20 straight months that means that
people's salaries and wages is not
keeping up with the pace of inflation
that's not good either and so the
question becomes how much damage is
being done to the economy well I've been
talking about this year all the way back
in April until now that there's a
possibility that the Federal Reserve is
going to actually raise their inflation
rate target it's been at two percent for
a while but now even folks like Bill
Ackman are talking about the possibility
of the FED increasing that Target rate
to about three percent it'd be a 50
increase in their target inflation rate
now as they do this doesn't really
change anything in terms of the economy
itself but it would require all
individuals and companies to start the
plan with a different number in mind
rather than counting on two percent
inflation or at least trying to get
there you'd now have to think their rate
is only going to be three percent and
that means that you're gonna have to
raise prices and likely pay your
employees more money now I don't know
when all this is going to happen but I
still think that the biggest story in
Bitcoin right now is the Federal Reserve
as they continue to tighten Financial
conditions we will see Bitcoin go
sideways or down it's going to be really
hard to get a risk on asset like Bitcoin
to recover until we return back to a
loose monetary policy that means it's
just a waiting game and if we use
history as a guide in deep bear markets
like this it's usually been a pretty
interesting time to just continue to
stack SATs dollar cost averaging into a
great asset and holding it for the long
term is one of those core financial
principles that's shared by people
across all strategies and asset classes
literally Warren Buffett and Charlie
Munger they talk about it all the time
and bitcoiners do too if you just apply
simple investing strategies to an asset
like Bitcoin then you're likely to be on
the better side of the probability
that's it for this week continue to keep
your eyes on the Federal Reserve and
I'll keep you updated as more develops
I'll see you all next Saturday